les témoignages qu'ils soient lus par la
cour ou fait de vive voix par les
victimes elles mêmes sont tous
édifiant voir confondant trop
impressionné par le statut de cet homme
que tout considéré comme un médecin
aucune d'entre elles n'a songé à se
débattre ni à fuir lors de ces séances
qui les mettait clairement de plus en
plus mal à l'aise elles se sont toutes
plier aux pratiques douteuses du
magnétiseur massage intime attouchements
position clairement connotée
sexuellement voir humiliation elles ont
tous subi tout supporter avant de
réaliser c'est là toute la difficulté de
ce procès jusqu'où le guérisseur est il
vraiment aller peut-on parler de
consentement lorsque les victimes se
disent tétanisé en état de sidération
parties civiles et défense s'oppose
violemment sur le sujet elles ont le
sentiment qu'il se passe des choses tout
à fait anormal à un moment donné parce
que dans un premier temps ils vont se
demander si c'est normal
et elles vont être complètement je
dirais prise
englué celle terme et donc elles sont
incapables de réagir et de même de
montrer qu'elles ne sont pas d'accord il
y en a quelques-unes qu'ils ont créée
qui ont réussi à écarter
monsieur pat mais pour la plupart elles
sont totalement englué la difficulté
c'est qu'on a de multiples témoignages
dans ce dossier qui vont dans les deux
sens les gestes ont toujours été les
mêmes toujours toutes les victimes ou
les témoins décrivent les mêmes gestes
et les mêmes soins pratiqués par le sais
pas tu es pour autant certaines ne
considère pas que c'est assimilable à
une agression sexuelle
les témoignages sont bouleversants à la
fois de naïveté et de souffrance les
voix se brise le silence est lourd
l'accusé prostré lève de temps à autre
les yeux sur ses victimes mais maintient
sa version des faits il n'a violé
personne ne se souvient de rien de
déplacé ses gestes étaient dit-il
purement thérapeutique
ils ont visiblement fait plus de mal que
de bien